[Musik]
die leute die dort auf diese
demonstration gehen sehen sich ja selbst
als demokraten sie aber die demokratie
verraten sind das linke neben nazis
demonstrieren verstehe ich absolut
überhaupt nicht ganz egal ob man
vielleicht einen punkt
ähnliche ängste oder forderung hat mit
plazes demonstriert man nicht das kann
ich an vormundschaftliche staat
plötzlich sozusagen das regime
übernehmen also das aber nicht eine
diktatur sondern die frage einfach
gerätes mäßigkeit
ein jahr pandemie zwischen lockdown und
lockerungen hoffen und bangen über leben
und sterben
ein ausnahmezustand der ans eingemachte
geht im verhältnis von bürger und staat
solidarität und egoismus verstärkt
polarisiert die bewegung zu diesem
paradox die querdenker hier marschieren
familien neben verschwörungs gläubigen
naturheilkundler neben nazis menschen
mit nachvollziehbaren sorgen neben
corona leugnern was hält sie zusammen
das hat jetzt die erste studie zum thema
rund um den soziologen oliver nachtwey
an der uni basel untersucht
selbst die wilden demonstration der 70er
und 80er jahre die häufig militant waren
und auch teilweise sagen sein gewalt
gewalttätige elemente hatten hatten zu
sagen als grundkonsens dieses element
was sie heute wegen auszeichnet nämlich
keine maske zu tragen und ist deutlich
eigentlich ein ganz starker
neoliberalismus ein ultra
individualismus vorhanden
der nämlich davon ausgeht ich möchte
meine freiheit ausleben möglicherweise
auch auf die kosten von anderen eine
postmoderne bewegung spiegel des
egozentrischen zeitalters die idee vom
recht auf grenzenlose persönliche
freiheit überwindet gräben 23 prozent
der befragten querdenker haben grün
gewählt und wählen jetzt afd
sie wollen direkte demokratie das
überdeckt blinde flecken demokraten die
sich als widerstandskämpfer in einer
diktatur sehen während sie geschützt von
demokratie und rechtsstaat verschwörungs
mythen verbreiten
und passieren eine demokratin der ich
liebe sie sehen sich vor allen dingen
eins gesellschaftskritiker aber sie
haben keinen anspruch mehr eine wirklich
co rente gesellschaftskritik auszügen
man beruft sich auf alle möglichen
versatzstücke hauptsache es ist kritisch
gegen das system also aus unserer sicht
steht dass kritiker da sein das
kritisieren als praxis im vordergrund
fast egal was der inhalt dieser kritik
ist die studie ist nicht repräsentativ
aber aussagekräftig unter den 1150
befragten aus deutschland und der
schweiz sind überdurchschnittlich viele
selbstständige und akademiker aus der
mittelschicht gebildete selfmade
menschen denken quer
der staat kommt jetzt massiv zurück
setzt neue regeln setzt menschen grenzen
in ihrer handlung und bedroht ihre
status position manchmal auch ihre
sprecher position die möglichkeit zu
sagen ich mache es anders ich mache es
so wie ich will
das ist plötzlich nicht möglich dieses
ressentiment ist das ressentiment der
etablierten die egalisiert werden
für das individuum gegen gleichmacherei
das ist auch die maxime der
anthroposophen viele von ihnen
engagieren sich in der querdenker
bewegung
die antworten sind in ihren
krankenhäusern an der scuola front
tatsächlich mit wir sind im kultur und
erziehungsbereich mit leidende ganz
stark so dass durch die einrichtung
teilweise ein riss zwischen den
befürwortern von den maßnahmen oder also
zu verstärken und den kritikern der
fehler liegt dann oft drinne das dann
weil man ein neues gesetz weil man ein
anderes gesellschaftssystem
erreichen will man fühlt sich nicht mehr
politisch vertreten wird irgendein
spektrum und springt auf das neue drauf
ohne genau zu gucken was dann dahinter
steckt und welche kräfte da sind es
scheint so dass vielen das wirklich ein
bisschen egal ist dass sie eben mit
antidemokraten die auch am ende
wahrscheinlich sie verfolgen würden auf
die straße gehen
die linke mitte hat diese radikal
demokraten verloren trotz radikalen
rhetorik wir müssen radikale antworten
geben radikal was wirklich radikale
linke parteien und organisationen wie
care pack distanzieren sich von der
querdenker bewegung stützen die korona
maßnahmen grundsätzlich das verstärkt
die gefühlte alternativlosigkeit bei
wütenden systemgegner ich glaube es um
zwei dinge schief gelaufen das eine ist
dass wir glaube ich denn den fehler
gemacht haben mit dem aufkommen der ahl
stehe und von peter bestimmte kritik an
bestimmten institution nämlich gerade
kritik an den medien kritik auch in der
wissenschaft per sie der rechten zu
überlassen
also stichwort lügen presst der zweite
fehler den ich sehe ist dass wir in der
vergangenheit vielleicht zu selten
diesen punkt explizit gemacht haben ja
wir kritisieren fehlentwicklungen ja es
läuft vielfalt statt an aber wir glauben
auch daran dass unser system lernen
verbesserungsfähig ist und wir
protestieren in der hoffnung mit dem
impetus unsere gesellschaft unsere
institutionen besser zu machen
viele querdenker haben dieses gemeinsame
system längst aufgegeben
wollen dessen realität die konstruieren
gleichzeitig erinnert die bewegung an
die tradition der lebensreformbewegung
mensch statt maschine zurück zur natur
wie zu beginn der industrialisierung und
in den 80ern als sich die grünen
formierten intuition stadt wissenschaft
querdenken der naturheilkundler und
impfgegner beschwören die alleinige
macht der selbstheilungskräfte was
überholte vorstellungen die impfstoffe
die derzeit eingesetzt werden
kopieren ja teilweise den virus und
diese antigene werden jetzt für den
körper aufbereitet zu antikörper abwehr
und deswegen sind es eigene leistungen
die der körper erst mal zu vollziehen
hat es wird er kann mit wie man
medikament passiv eingenommen sondern es
wird der organismus aktiv geht es im
sinne seiner abwehr gegen diesen erreger
unterstützt
und deswegen ist das nicht gegen die
natur kunde naturromantik stadt
ganzheitlicher fortschritt viele
wahrheiten der bewegung sind für die
mehrheit waren das gefühl ausgegrenzt zu
sein radikalisiert diesem kreislauf
durchbrechen könnte eine neue
aufgeklärte und solidarische
gesellschaftskritik mich fragt warum
müssen alle kinder jetzt zu hause
bleiben aber die fabriken bleiben offen
auch wenn sie keine lebensmittel
herstellt wie kann es sein dass in
dieser pandemie die milliardäre einen
enormen vermögenswachstum erfahren haben
während gleichzeitig die personen in den
unteren berufsgruppen die höchsten
arbeitsrichter berufs risiken risiken
vor arbeitslosigkeit einkommensverlusten
haben und auch die höchsten co mit
risiken haben
ein jahr ausnahmezustand der erst
langsam absehbar was wird dann aus den
neuen verqueren koalitionen
[Musik]